[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci nous retrouver pour
ce nouveau numéro de vip
aujourd'hui j'ai la chance et la joie de
recevoir marie-pierre d-link siggers
marica ding séguin bonjour bonjour
comment ça va mieux que l'an dernier à
la même époque
mais bon ça n'y avait pas échappé au
virus à ce que je crois alors marie
pierre poux ceux qui ont regardé les
autres émissions qui vous était consacré
bah y'a rien à dire mais pour ceux qui
ne vous connaissent pas parce que ça
fait la troisième fois que vous nous
faites là l'amitié de venir sur ce
plateau la même c'est en virtuel vous là
vous sortez un dernier livre qui
s'appelle debout la force de s'incarner
la dernière fois où vous étiez venu pour
un autre livre qui s'appelait comment il
s'appelait cet autre livre il s'appelait
osé incarner 12 clés pour être soi voilà
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
en deux mots quelle est votre mission de
thérapeutes votre travail car vous êtes
thérapeute conférencière et auteure
mon travail est un travail depuis depuis
plus de 25 ans d'accompagnement des
personnes qui ont rencontré à un moment
donné dans leur villa je parlerai
d'incarnation un obstacle une difficulté
et qui en ont qui cherchent à en
comprendre le sens
il ya aussi tous ceux et celles qui
intervient en mode pré en préventif se
posant des questions de fond l'objectif
étant toujours pour moi devise est
d'accompagner l'autonomie individuelle
d'accord de donner aux gens les clés
pour que après vous avoir parlé se
débrouille tout seul avec une pointe qui
est important et un maximum de clés et
transmis par mes ouvrages sachant qu'en
fait je me définis pas forcément comme
thérapeute parce que ça l'est mais de
manière un petit peu particulière parce
que il n'y a pas besoin de rendez vous
successifs
je recommande des thérapeutes
mais mon travail est toujours au rayon
laser sur une problématique particulière
pour en dénouer l'écheveau un moment
d'accord et vous travaillez donc avec
l'énergétique chinoise c'est bien ça
c'est le job mais outils il ya aussi la
théorie young n ya aussi il ya toute une
palette d'outils en partie bien sûr
parfait alors ce dernier livre là debout
qui est là comment est-ce qu'il
s'inscrit par rapport au premier le
premier vous la fin pas le premier jeudi
à celui d'avant parce que c'est votre
troisième livre celui d'avant donc vous
l'avez écrit il ya un peu plus d'un an
donc celui ci arrive plutôt vite et a
commencé à être est il par rapport à
l'autre alors on peut dire que il est le
troisième volume d'une série 1
mais avec un angle beaucoup plus direct
quand on la responsabilité que nous
avons de vivre pleinement et de ne pas
attendre que les obstacles nous la
maladie nous montre le chemin
ce livre je ne pensais pas écrire un
troisième livre à ce stade là le second
venait de sortir mais je me sens et donc
je il ya eu une urgence avant même que
la pandémie arrive pour moi de même sur
le papier des des informations des
conseils nous permettant de nous repérer
de naviguer à vue dans une période dont
je savais qu'elle allait être difficile
donc les clés sont denses et ouvre cet
ouvrage qui s'est plutôt imposé à moi
que je ne les prévu mais comme il était
sûr d'urgence est impossible à freiner
il fallait que ça sorte de dire que cela
fait des semaines et dans mon travail
aussi en conférence un de décodage des
énergies temporel donc là on est
vraiment dans la tradition chinoise de
mettre des mots sur les qualités
énergétiques des années je m'épuise est
quand même avec plaisir mais je m'épuise
est à prévenir
a insisté sur l'importance de nous
repositionner de revenir à une posture
individuel de centrage d'économie de
force mais en même temps je voyais que
j'étais entendu bien sûr par un certain
nombre de personnes mais le monde
semblait-il eux allaient avoir besoin
d'un point d'arrêt pour se recentrer et
ce livre est au service de ce qui nous
permet d'être debout ou de nous remettre
debout
voilà j'allais venir pourquoi ce titre
de boue déjà c'est assez fort est ce que
pour vous les gens sont couchés en
général vous avez ce sentiment
alors on va peut-être pas rentrer en
mode binaire occidentale du match était
très juste
véronique si je me font très rapidement
je dirais oui nous sommes couchés devant
la souffrance nous sommes couchés devant
nos peurs nous sommes couchés
on ne sachant pas vers quelle direction
aller que là on y est encore à un
confinement confinement des confinement
est donc mon travail
il est de permettre ni d'accès un levier
personnel on ne peut pas être manipulés
par des peurs ils sont pas les nôtres
voir des hommes évitables et peuplements
notre place ok alors moi j'ai envie
qu'on rentre dans la structure même de
votre livre donc on a une préface de
fabrice vidal qui est un enseignant en
méditation et un bouddhiste et renault
mais voilà après il ya votre
introduction mais l'a finalement vous
nous expliquer le pourquoi du comment de
ce livre est alors il ya une première
partie qui s'appelle les neuf défis
d'incarnation c'est vous qui les avez
défini ses 9 des filles est ce qu'on
peut vous me donnez un exemple j'avais
envie de parler d'eux
la préservation du coeur par exemple
mais allez-y jouer donc ce que ce que
j'ai fait c'est vraiment le résultat
d'une pratique quotidienne
d'accompagnement très inspiré forcément
de la pensée chinoise dans lequel il ya
aussi les arts martiaux et donc je suis
les jours au contact d'un impalpable
collectif qui est en fait une souffrance
qui ne se dit pas un break lorsque j'ai
à faire c'est de mettre au service du
monde des points de lecture qui
permettent de réintroduire du sens qu'on
trouve ou qu'on trouve pas ailleurs on
va peut-être trouvé dans certains
ouvrages de chinoiseries difficile à
lire et donc par exemple alors donnez
moi un exemple
par exemple sur la question de ce
chapitre qui est préservé le corps qui
est un aîné fille l'incarnation et des
filles à nous nous minimisons trop
souvent l'impact de situation nous avons
été des aînés ou mal aimé
enfin il appelait mardan je vous couvre
juste de seconde est ce que c'est ce que
vous appelez se faire voler son coeur
absolument absolument impliquer moi
c'est l'onuci dans son canton quand on
voit les personnes qui sont en mode
répétitif à se rendre compte tous se
retrouver par exemple si on est très
spécifique assure des situations de
d'amour contrariée et sema vous voulez
dire pardon qui reproduisent des schémas
négatif d'un stock
alors ça c'est oui mais c'est presque
culpabilisant de le dire comme ça moi je
n'ai pas ces personnes là sont à la
recherche d'un morceau du port seul
qu'ils ont perdu soit très jeune dans
leur vie soit au fil des années et dense
est en se basant sur l'énergétique
chinoise 1 nous sommes fait de nos
émotions
nous stockons nos émissions nous ito
qu'on ôte roma a donc gagné
le biais d'exercices et de questions
simples que je donne à la pêche de ces
partis d'eux-mêmes qui est rentré en
hibernation comme dans les contes je
cite aussi des contes un des exemples
concrets des exercices à effectuer et
vous donner aussi des interprétations de
compte ce qui rend votre livre
extrêmement vivant et concret et facile
d'approché
et quand vous dites pas et donc chaque
vie nous fait avancer sur le chemin de
la différenciation est ce que c'est
c'est sa dette notre but de vie de ted
différent de trouver nos différences pas
absolument elle c'est à dire que chadli
mettons qu'on en est qu on n'a pas
besoin de s'imaginer qu'ils aient
plusieurs plusieurs vies mais le pot
moore a une vie réussie est une vie où
nous arrivons à poser nos différents nos
qualités et et non pas à nous conformer
à ce qu il est attendu de nous forcément
oui parce qu'on se laisse souvent
aveuglés pas ce qu'on attend de nous
qu'on nous a martelé durant des années
voilà je fais la comparaison avec peau
d'âne par exemple un ou ce qu'il est
attendu de nous mêmes par des parents
qui sont bienveillantes a fini par nous
engluer dans une voie qui n'est pas
forcément la nôtre donc tout contrat
voire excellent sur ce qu'elle est
pardon je faisais je vous ai coupé oui
et du camp où une fois qu'on est englué
ça nous empêche de rayonner d'être nous
mêmes à la bonne place et au bon moment
et et voilà alors on va allergies
malaise oui je dirais qu'en vie en noir
et blanc
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'ils sont
vivants couleurs à d'accord mais écoutez
vos repas alors pour ça je continue dans
l'avancée dans ma lecture du livre
j'avais envie qu'on parle aussi des huit
parade
parce que ça c'est très concret comment
vous est venue cette idée de parler
d'élus parade nyala
de tout le travail sur le corps
l'influencent des arts martiaux je
constate bien souvent que nous vivons
dans l'illusion d'une société qui nous
protège à tous les niveaux alors que
dans la réalité nous sommes seuls bien
souvent à gérer des épreuves
donc je propose 8 posture on lâche me en
fonction de ce que nous vivons il y en a
une qui est comme un canard laisser
couler laisser glisser le canari les os
ou ses plumes dans certains cas ne pas
répondre à l'affront est la bonne
donc ce sont des huit parade pour en
fait se défendre c'est ce que vous dites
de deux fonctions de l'agression
absolument
voilà parce que vous dites aussi
qu'aujourd'hui on n'apprend pas à se
défendre
vous parlez d'une d'une augmentation de
la souffrance et d'une augmentation des
agressions et vous vont c'est que les
gens ne savent pas se défendre et pas de
la bonne manière apparemment toujours
est il est ce que est ce que l'on va moi
j'ai appris à ma fille à se défendre
quand elle est encore à la crèche parce
qu'elle se faisait mans tous les jours
et personne intervenait donc ça ne s'est
pas de devenir agressif c'est de repérer
l'agression qui peut-être mental tu peux
tu être verbale qui peut être physique
exposition histoire après parce que
notre destin n'est pas un destin de
souffrance ni de soumission notre destin
il est d'y vivre
voilà sans être soumis non plus aux
obstacles et aux aléas de la vie
ils vont venir il y en a il ya pas de
viande m
mes positions nous c'est aussi de sortir
d'une posture où nous serions
culpabiliser et responsables de ce
qu'ils déconnent dans notre vie dans un
certain nombre de cas l'obstacle va être
une opportunité de repositionnement même
s'il fait mal à ses traits chinois ouais
ouais ok super mahé pia je voulais juste
vous demander pour 2021 qu'est ce que
vous nous dites alors 2021
l'année du boeuf de métal on est sorti
je suis obligé de dire qu'on est sorti
de 2020 qui est hellène est la plus
turbulente d'espoir sans canne et
chinoises d'être montrées dans et 13 ans
crée donc moins de turbulences
mais cette année favorise en particulier
ceux qui vont savoir être trois choses
patients constructif et hyper réactif
quand tout d'un coup il ya une
opportunité d'avancer
ok bah écoutez c'est bien entendu
hyperréactif je prends merci marie
pierre alors je recommande à tout le
monde la lecture de ce livre que qu'on
définit aussi comme une boîte à outils
on peut lire un peu dans tous les sens
vous on continue on trouvera toujours un
peu une réponse à nos problèmes et c'est
une grande aide vraiment merci beaucoup
nous communiquer tout ça et j'ai envie
de vous embrasser puisqu'on est loin ça
est-ce que rien voilà et très vite
j'espère merci marie pierre et je
recommande vraiment au ce livre de boue
voilà on va tous se lever à bien tg
pouvoir par une veine de vous mais moi
aussi je suis debout
m